[Music]
with great power
comes great responsibility
you bet it does and if you're the
creative team behind spider-man no way
home that responsibility was to give the
fans what they wanted and what we wanted
was a recreation of this viral meme the
team did not disappoint
they get us
they really get us and now the team is
taking fans behind the scenes of that
moment showing how much fun actors tom
holland andrew garfield and toby mcguire
had recreating the meme on set
focus trust your tingle
i have the tingle thing just not for
bread
you are amazing thank you yeah will you
say it no i kind of needed to hear that
thank you
peter one
eight or two
you know three
i love you
yeah
guys
looks like the guys had absolutely no
fun shooting that at all okay so last
week andrew garfield opened up about the
quote out of body experience on the pink
carpet at the 2022 costume designers
guild awards sharing that when it came
to the spidey suit he was definitely the
most demanding i mean it was just funny
it just it was just kind of hilarious
that we were
together and it was surreal it was kind
of an outer body experience i had like
zip zip zippers in my wrist so i can
free my hands when i needed to um i had
a zipper between the weight the the
bottom half of the top half which
neither of them had so i i
i think i probably kicked up a lot of
a lot of fuss when i was playing the
character i was like
you need to make me comfortable but the
other two are much more polite than i
was
you